there is no one in the world that could
play Maleficent except for Angela Julie
seeing her for the first time back in
the black cloak and warns it's very
exciting I'm sure your kind would agree
maleficents a character people used to
think of is one thing and now we know
more of who she is do you in this film
we posed the question are we all good
are we all bad what exactly are you
implying Angelina has that charisma
that's so very kind of you
she's able to bring all of the strength
to Maleficent she's a force of nature
life says not just dark she's actually
playful she's just otherworldly it takes
your breath away
Maleficent is such an incredible
larger-than-life character hello beastie
my love laughs she's like my alter ego
hmm she's so iconic
humans are hilarious
[Music]
okay
[Music]
to see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
must be season
five years ago I thought I lost you
forever
there is no curse that could ever tell
me away from you will you marry me yes
[Music]
mistress I have a little bit of news
don't ruin my morning
never asked me to marry him no I wasn't
really asking nor was I love doesn't
always end well beasty trust me
let us prove you wrong you have done an
admirable job going against your own
nature to raise this child but now he
will finally get the love of a real
mother tonight I consider Elora
my what have you done
Maleficent is a threat to everyone
because you are bested hell
[Applause]
one can never be too careful
[Music]
you
you do not know me
tell me what happened there was another
creature
we've spent years caring for a shoe
now it's time to care for your own
[Music]